[Applaudissements]
alors là les amis on va danser alors
appelé avec la jonah hill on va n'est
d'ailleurs pas vrai mais ils ont ramené
le niveau devient le père sans danser
tous nous on s'est dit voilà avec
mathieu on va prouver qu'on peut faire
tout à fait au même niveau les danses de
danse avec les stars 2 samedi là du
dernier prime
je vous mets au défi de retrouver ou et
mathieu et moi où sont les autres
candidats on dirais exactement tef samba
khary et son partenaire
galerie courtois
j'ai retrouvé mes jambes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouvert à tous les coups on va parler
avec nous attend pas mal de choses au
john lambert looking for kim le
spectacle